[Musique]
ce couple tranquille c'est claude
chabrol et stéphane audran ils cultivent
leur jardin la paix au foyer et l'amour
des bêtes en trois ans ils ont tourné
ensemble
trois histoires de mariage tragique la
rupture la femme infidèle et maintenant
juste avant la nuit
leur mariage à eux se portent bien merci
mais ça n'a pas toujours été aussi
simple c'est un mari est pas tant parce
que il est drôle il s'intéresse pas
seulement à son métier qui est quand
même un métier drôle et enfin vous savez
il s'intéresse aussi autre chose à quoi
pour tout ça à la musique à la politique
je m'aperçois que je laime quand même
assez profondément parce que je ne veux
plus quand elle est là que quand elle
n'est pas là et c'est très très rare
comment vous êtes vous rencontrés tu te
raconte tous deux rencontres c'est que
moi je veux rencontrer elle est venue au
bureau au moment des cousins avec gérard
blanc oui moi je voulais tout à fait
rencontrer chabrol parce que je lisais
les cahiers du cinéma et je trouvais les
articles de charbon très drôle alors je
suis allé voir dans son bureau et
merveille des merveilles il prêt il
préparait les cousins il m'a dit bon
d'accord vous faites quelque chose avant
j'ai trouvé très bonne dans les cousins
mais elle m'avait fait très peur parce
que moment on avait besoin d'elle
n'était jamais là elle était toujours
partie on a été obligé noyer les
télégrammes pour lui dire de venir
tourner vous êtes dit pas sérieuse j'ai
pas très bon et puis quand même on
rigolait bien pendant ce tournage
et alors quand j'ai voulu faire les
bonnes femmes j'ai dire que je vais la
prendre parce que les marrante
cependant les bonnes femmes que j'ai que
je me suis que j'ai réalisé que derrière
cette actrice se cacher qu'une femme qui
m'a également qui m'a séduit comme ça il
vous a fallu deux films il tombé
amoureux d'elle oui aussi un est elle
facile de films
ça n'est pas le coup de foudre qua non
non non non non non ça pose quand même
des problèmes de faire tourner sa femme
je fais je dis que je disais que
j'aimerais bien faire tourner ce thème
le il y avait une espèce de veto presque
systématique a besoin il va faire
tourner sa femme
on connaissait habitants s'ils ont
toujours un tromblon l'acquis qui traite
d'un virus qui veut lui coller à tous à
toutes les sauces c'était épouvantable
pour ça j'ai eu beaucoup de beaucoup de
déboires à moi j'arrivais à me dire
qu'ils voulaient me faire tourner et
ponctue un plaisir ça a été plus facile
après les biches parce que dans les
biches pour la première fois aujourd'hui
mais stéphane audran mais quelle actrice
mais qu'elle est belle et c'est pour ça
que je voulais toujours continuer pour
parce que je me dis peut-être qu'un jour
ça va se débloquer qu'un jour ça va
thoune est intéressant quand claude
prépare un film comment ça se passe au
moment où il écrit
il se réveille tôt il se réveille la
nuit il ya des angoisses alors j'ai hâte
que vraiment la gestation soit fini ils
se réveillent pour penser y pense très
fort ça me réveille aussi des fois ils
regardent la télé en écoutant de la
musique
il écrit et joue aux dés en écrivant son
scénario et il suit bien fil de son idée
ça faut lui demander mais enfin c'est ce
que je vois qu'il fait je peux pas
suivre autrement à venir c'est le 10
heures je sais pas pourquoi ça serait
alors la musique la télé si les découpes
chose je viens quand je réfléchis
beaucoup il faut beaucoup de choses à la
fois
pourquoi n'avez vous jamais fait un film
réellement un story c'est entre
énormément faut choisir un sujet qu'ils
puissent qui puisse séduire la foule et
qui ne finissent pas par coûter trop
cher pourquoi cette prudence je fais
cinq films qui ont marché dessus donc je
peux me payer je peux me payer un lobby
des échecs quoi mais en même temps après
cet échec je me retrouve dans une
situation où j'aurai des difficultés les
difficultés un truc qui m'intéresse
vraiment alors comme j'en ai
complètement ac 2-2 de ne pas faire ce
que j'ai envie de faire de d'être obligé
de travailler à la commande comme ça je
sais mieux prendre des précautions dont
je m'habille avons été amenés à
travailler à la commande
eh bien j'ai fait quatre buts de suite
ce qui est énorme et puis après j'ai
fait un succès enfin oui un succès enfin
film qu'avait apporté de l'argent qui
était longue rue mais il ya une chose
formidable au cinéma c'est que le la
pensée va lentement pris landru qu'à
marcher
ils sont venus me dit quoi est ce garçon
a fait 4 bide donc je suis resté deux
ans son tour du web de quoi on vit des
problèmes d'argent je mendier un petit
peu de sous un producteur là j'ai allégé
pas d'argent c'est un producteur
faucheurs nous il faut travailler alors
je dis je vais à travers l'oeil mais il
faut cinquante mille belle passe et les
salins savait pas où il les prenait
lui-même face été et ce programme
éthique ce sont les problèmes d'argent
quel serait le plus grand drame qui
pourrait arriver dans le ménage chabrol
audran
très égoïstement je vis dans un bonheur
que je trouve qui me convient
parfaitement et qui est comme tous les
bonheurs abbas d'équilibré cette rupture
d'équilibré le prévenu est de 36 chose
enfin le c'est ça qui me ferait peur que
vous avez l'air de vous organiser pour
éviter les pépins
oui serge heures on s'est même une
philosophie comment fait on il faut
faire attention il faut de
l'anticipation il faut près faut prévoir
les les pépins qui peuvent arriver les
points qui vont arriver essayer de les
supprimer avant
[Musique]